le changement
un vrai changement un an après
l'élection de justin trudeau
c'est l'année des grandes décisions lui
même l'a 10 des années les plus
difficiles de son mandat
moi je retiens trois gros enjeu à
surveiller les pipelines l'équilibré
budgétaire et la réforme électorale les
pipelines c'est sûr au québec on parle
peu une semaine qui passe encore parle
du pipeline d énergie est l'opposition
la contreverse ecce terra
mais ce débat est plus large que ça
premièrement la prochaine décision
difficile que devra prendre le
gouvernement trudeau
c'est sur un autre type lean à l'autre
bout du pays qu'il lui morgen
mais au delà du fait de dire oui non
pour contre un oléoduc ou un autre très
difficile dans le débat sur les oléoducs
c'est qu'on a vraiment le choc entre
développer l'économie canadienne
permettre au secteur pétrolier de
rebondir de trouver des nouveaux marchés
et transformer l'économie canadienne
pour se sevrer des changements
climatiques et tout ça
l' équilibre budgétaire et là je vous
parle pas du déficit zéro parce que
sérieux avec un déficit qui feront les
30 milliards de dollars l'an dernier
s'imagine pas qu'on va revenir au
déficit zéro avant la fin du mandat
trudeau le problème c'est qu'au moment
où monsieur doit fait sa promesse de
déficit de 10 milliards de dollars par
année pendant trois ans juste pour
repartir l'économie étudiera économie
canadienne allait beaucoup mieux qu'elle
ne voit maintenant là là on écrit le
prochain budget le gouvernement se
demande qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant
est ce qu'on continue à dépenser ou est
ce qu'il faut faire des choix différents
où on investit il faut trouver les bon
levier la réforme électorale
il ya plein de monde qui baptisa c'est
pas intéressant et je des roms et
pourtant c'est vraiment le la prémisse
de toutes les voix ensoleillée un de
justin trudeau de dire on va redonner
une pertinence à la politique on va
lutter contre le cynisme des gens la
première chose c'est de changer le mode
de scrutin
comment assurer la légitimité de
nouveaux modes pour élire nos
politiciens au canada sans faire de
référendum comme le demandent les
conservateurs une raison très simple
c'est que le gouvernement post en faire
un référendum pourra changer la loi
référendaire adopter une nouvelle loi
gtrra on n'a pas le temps de faire ça
c'est pas un des dossiers où on a une
des ministres les plus fortes du
gouvernement et le chu poli en vérité
pas la brossette jusqu'ici a pas réussi
à faire preuve de beaucoup de leadership
avec ses avec les partis d'opposition
alors ce n'est que le début mai chez les
trois que j'ai choisi parce que je pense
que c'est les plus symptomatiques et les
plus est plus important puis beaucoup de
gens aussi qui pensent à la marijuana
c'est donc face et la première qu'on
allait réussir à la légaliser maintenant
il faut y arriver en assurant de
protéger les jeunes
trouvant le juste équilibre ça c'est un
défi majeur mais peut-être que ce sera
notre grand défi à surveiller pour le
début de baisse